do your robert de niro impression eh
i guess uh hello i'm robert de niro
hey it's not so good hey show him sure
hey i'm robert de niro hey hey
he could take a little kid saying and
turn it into a tough guy phrase
somebody comes and say the mob is going
to kick your butt be like you sir
are a liar lion liar
your pants are on fire
and um you know maybe i talk like this
you know
i look like um i look like maybe i just
ate a lemon
or something you know i got bad gas huh
you're talking to me huh i'll break your
legs
i'll break your legs put them back
together and i'll break them again
you do what you do i do what i gotta do
if i'm there and i gotta put you away
i won't like it but if it's between you
and some poor bastard whose wife you're
gonna turn into a widow
brother you are going down
[Music]
[Applause]
you got that scene where they meet for
the first time pacino's sitting there
with de niro
he's bringing [ __ ] down to him he's like
you sir i'm a bad guy
i am the police it's my job to stop guys
like you
murderers rapers killers that's what i
do
there may come a time when i pass cross
i'm gonna have to take you down i don't
like it but i'll do it keeps me hot
on my toes where i gotta be
de niro comes back you know there's a
flip side to that coin
good friend of mine jimmy once told me
never get attached to anything that you
cannot walk out on in 15 seconds flat if
you spot the heat
coming around the corner and i also like
guys like you that like guys like me
because you keep me hot
on my toes where i gotta pick
and you're right i patch they may cross
i'm gonna have to take you down
i won't like it but i will not hesitate
well like i'm so i'm on your show right
but bob's on your show yeah all right
you gotta ask me a quick oh oh
so bob how are you yeah thank you
now this film the good shepherd it's
pretty impressive piece of work
if you wanted a free meal where would
you go
yo yeah yeah yes i yeah you
get it i get hungry you know that that's
exactly spot on that's the exact
conversation we had
you know i like to sweep potatoes mom
i look around the table i don't see it
i'll sweep a thought
what do you want to do man you want to
play a game you want to play a game
huh i see the jello with the wallets man
every time you thought the jello goes
down my throat the wallets get stuck in
my
he calls me on the phone he goes alec
they told me they want me to do your
talk show
uh they said they wanted me to sit down
and interview you for an hour
an hour an hour it was alec i got to ask
you a question
what are we going to talk about for an
hour
here's al used to uh he'd lean over and
he'd go
john
skeleton goes into a bar
orders a beer and a mop
[Applause]
no
no jimmy
they asked me they asked me to do the uh
go over there and see fallon you know to
promote the movie i said foul
i don't think so
i don't think so you know what
i said go [ __ ] yourself
basically i um i don't want to bother
you
okay i don't want to bother you
i just wish to god that this guy
would stop i don't want
to bother you i'm sorry
had you worked with the nero before this
film anywhere no had you had you met him
anywhere
oh gosh well i that on the show i met
him and then i um
i had a whole long history that he
wasn't aware of
um that i i auditioned for for a movie i
put myself on tape for a movie
that uh to play his son and my mother my
mother played him
and he actually saw the tape and called
me in to meet him oh that's nice yeah
that was yeah that was uh and i was a
mess and i couldn't believe it and
i sat down and he just said uh he didn't
say much he just said uh
yeah i uh i see it i see you
i uh i see it um
okay you're playing dandy
you're playing d this whole apartment
it's playing dandy
the frankenstein monster he was in mary
shelley's frankenstein are you picturing
that robert de niro playing the
frankenstein monster
[Applause]
look at me huh
i am the frankenstein monster
i have bolts in my neck i'm electric and
scary
if i walk into this kitchen
and i see a cantaloupe
on that table i will lose
my mind
a lot of actors started doing bad
commercials remember robert de niros
now that's a spicy meet the ball
how to do the perfect al pacino
impression
in three easy steps
one where did it go
i call this step where did it go
because al always seems to be looking
for something that he's lost
now he he doesn't necessarily know what
it is
but he still can't find it so because
you're all sitting
i'm going to sit and help you learn how
to do this so so you have to start by
searching for something that has gone
missing
where is it my wallet my
my passport my toothbrush
my lines my performance whoa where did
that go
step two is the surprise al
for some reason always looks a little
surprised
if you look at his face it's like what
just happened
the last thing i remember i was snorting
a wheelbare full of cocaine and scarface
and now
i'm sitting next to the president whoa
how did that happen
and then finally step three is the huff
al seems to have a lot of air
[Music]
he's got to get out whoa
i blow it up but it just comes right
back in